BONITA STEWART: Good
afternoon everyone.
I'm Bonita Stewart, and I
lead our Global Partnerships
at Google.
And I've been at the New
York City Office since 2006,
so this is an exciting
afternoon for us.
And I am absolutely
honored to bring
to the stage, the entire cast,
as well as the playwright
and director of Eclipsed.
So let's give them a
warm Google welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Now as they're--
as the cast is--
as everyone's getting situated,
the one thing to know about
this particular Broadway play,
is that they've actually made
history.
And this is the first,
believe it or not,
in 2016, the first Broadway
play that was directed by,
written by, and
starring all women.
I personally had the opportunity
to see the play about two
weeks ago.
So I will not have-- I won't
have any spoiler alerts.
But it's such a gripping
story and I encourage
all Googlers to attend.
So one of the things that
we've done is that each of you
will receive a 34% discount
to actually go see the play.
You'll want the go link so
its go/eclipsed-discount.
So just keep that in mind
as we hear from our guests
here today.
So Danai, let's start with you.
And we're going to
introduce-- have
each one introduce the cast
and the role in the play.
Why don't you give the audience
the context of the play itself.
Entertainment Weekly called the
play harrowing, heartbreaking.
And I'm not going
to give me a spoiler
alerts here, but, a glimmer
of humor In this environment.
And you, personally,
have just spanned--
you've been an actress
in the Walking Dead,
and now you're an award
winning playwright.
So what inspired you
to write this play
and what message were you trying
to convey to men and women
everywhere?
DANAI GURIRA: Wow.
OK.
So why I write is
really quite basic.
I'm a Zimbabwean-American.
I am an African woman,
and I was outraged.
You know, I'm driven by outrage.
And I was driven by the outrage
that there were so few stories
that reflected that experience.
The experience of African women.
The stories of women
of African origin.
So that really is
my artistic mandate,
is to make sure
that these voices--
these faces are front and center
in whatever I create, anyway.
So that's really at
the core of everything
I do and of course
Eclipsed is no exception.
In terms of the exact story, I
came across an article about,
actually the liberation
fighters-- well rebel fighters
as many different
perspectives on what
they were these ladies were.
But they were in
the Lord Rebel Army,
which is one of the rebel
factions that were fighting
against Charles Taylor.
And when I came
across this article,
actually in the
New York Times, it
was these women who
were just really
clad in these
really cool clothes,
and really looked kind of cool.
They're like early 20s,
and they have these AK-47s
slung around their backs.
And I had just never
seen anything like it.
I grew up in southern
Africa during peace time
so I had never seen a war.
I'd never seen the
images of women in war,
and I knew that was a
story I had to pursue,
in whichever way,
shape, or form I could.
And so that's where the
journey really began.
I only actually started to
pursue it a few years later,
because I had another
play in between.
But it became a journey
that I didn't expect.
I went to Liberia.
Met women who really
devastated and astounded
me, and inspired
me, and entrusted me
with their stories.
And ultimately, I synthesized
it into this story.
In terms of what I want, it's
very interesting the idea
of a message, you know.
Because as a playwright
I think you're not--
you can't really
pursue a message.
You're not a pastor.
You're not-- you're
a storyteller.
And all you can
do is really hope
that the story
connects and relates
to people in whatever way.
So I don't know how it will
relate to her versus to him,
but I hope that at some
point somewhere in there,
they will lose their
sense of time and place,
and they will start to feel
a human connection to what's
happening on the stage and to
the characters that maybe they
never really ever get to see.
Which is kind of the
goal of what I write.
It's really about trying to
give those voices a space.
So that's the goal really.
Is to say, is there really
a difference between you
and any of these women up here?
You know, because I think that's
what happens to African women.
We get other otherized.
We get put in a category of the
other, and those over there,
and you know, wh-- statistics.
And so the goal is
really to decimate that,
and to make it
something where you
have to walk out
and feel that there
is no difference between
you in those people.
They are connected to you.
It's just geography.
And if you were in a
situation this dire,
you could end up,
kind of, probably
responding in a way that's kind
of similar to one of these five
women.
Like, it's the same
as the Walking Dead,
actually, funnily.
The premise.
It is.
It's who would you be if
the world got this dire?
You'd be one of them.
And that's really the goal.
The humor, yeah it's strategic
because it takes down guards.
If you're laughing,
you're getting
more and more connected.
You're finding yourself
more involved and more--
more in love with these people.
And so once again, they
can't be the other anymore.
That really sums it up.
BONITA STEWART: Great.
Thank you Danai.
So, Saycon?
SAYCON SENGBLOH: Saycon.
BONITA STEWART: Saycon, yes.
Let's start with you.
This his wife number one.
But why don't you
introduce yourself
to the audience and
the role that you play.
And if anyone wants to go into
character we're-- we're fine
with that.
SAYCON SENGBLOH: Hey, you
want me to bring my character
to the stage?
Yes, Hi everybody.
Thank you Google for having us.
I'm Saycon Sengbloh, and
I do play wife number one.
And-- do you-- what
was the other question?
Just next person?
DANAI GURIRA: And Helena.
SAYCON SENGBLOH: And Helena.
Yes.
Wife number one, AKA Helena.
PASCALE ARMOND: Pascale Armand.
I play Bessie,
wife number three.
AKOSUA BUSIA: Akosua Busia.
I play the peace woman.
So since you said go into
character, peace be with you.
And Rita.
She's also called Rita.
LIESL TOMMY: I'm Liesl
Tommy and I'm the director.
ZAINAB JAH: I'm Zainab Jah and
I play former wife number two.
Disgruntled.
BONITA STEWART: The soldier.
ZAINAB JAH: And the soldier.
LUPITA NYONG'O: I'm Lupita
Nyong'o and I play wife number
four.
Also known as, The Girl.
BONITA STEWART: Yes.
Yes.
So, Lupita.
I work up with all of
our publishing partners.
And so when I saw the picture on
the cover of In Style, and then
having seen the play, you
know, just a couple weeks ago.
But the juxtaposition of,
just the character, and I
do want to just take a
moment, because I'm still
beaming from the
Oscars when Lupita won.
And so I just think,
on behalf of all of us,
congratulations on your
Oscar for 12 Years a Slave.
LUPITA NYONG'O: Thank you.
BONITA STEWART: Now you play
the character of The Girl
And I saw you, in that
character, tremble on stage.
And being in the audience,
the entire theater
trembled with you because
of your character.
And at the Oscars, and
I still remember this,
you said, no matter where you're
from your dreams are valid.
So can you tell us a little
bit about your character
and the dreams that you
felt that The Girl had.
And maybe share a little
bit with the audience
on why this was so important
for that character.
LUPITA NYONG'O: Well, excuse me.
So The Girl is our way into the
world that Danai brings us to.
The play takes place in a
compound where a rebel soldier
is holding these women captive.
They're his sex
slaves, his wives.
And The Girl is the newest
addition to this compound.
And so, really, we learn
the rules of this world
through her eyes because
she's the new one.
She's absorbing it
for the first time
and she's learning how
to be in a world at war.
And so she goes through
a very, very large arc
from being completely
green, to knowing way
more than a 15-year-old should.
And, I think, Danai
talks about why
she called this play Eclipsed
because-- she's right here,
she can talk about it.
Well, I'm going to try.
It's about the fact
that the women we meet
have a light in them that is
momentarily eclipsed by war.
And so, I think that is like the
symbol, really, or the metaphor
that we see the girl go
into a total eclipse.
And yes, so I think
she starts off
having dreams and goals
and ambitions and a future.
And war changes what her
future might look like.
And dot, dot, dot,
come see the play.
BONITA STEWART: Great.
So Liesl.
As the director,
tell us a little bit
about the naming convention.
Because we have-- the
wives are nameless.
But maybe give us the
back story on that.
And also, as you were
directing Eclipsed,
how with this ensemble of
women-- phenomenal women,
I must say, how were
you trying to create
the sisterhood across
the various characters
within the play?
LIESL TOMMY: Well,
Danai can answer
the question about the naming.
BONITA STEWART: Go ahead, Danai.
Because it's interesting-- it's.
DANAI GURIRA: OK.
You mean how they are
named amongst each other?
BONITA STEWART: Yeah, just the
fact that there are one, two--
DANAI GURIRA: Right.
Well they're ranked
because they're
with a commanding officer.
So they're literally
being ranked,
and he's sort of reflecting
his ranking of their very--
his very ragtag rebel army in
how he deals with his wives.
It's also supposed to, I
guess, in a very brash way,
reflect an idea of a
polygamous family situation.
But of course it's, right,
but of course it's an end.
So the ranking does involve
power order, in a sense
as well.
And yes, so then there's--
they don't really tend to use
their own names and the
namelessness that is reflected
in the play was about the
idea that-- the identity--
the eclipsing that occurs
through these dire circumstance
that, of course, is
none of their making.
So that's kind of
the quick answer.
BONITA STEWART:
Liesl, do you want
to follow on the ensemble
and the sisterhood?
LIESL TOMMY: Sure.
So when Danai and I started
working on this play
about five or six years ago,
I got it in an early draft
and after page five I knew
that it was something profound
and that she was doing--
she was pushing form.
She was writing in a way
that I had not yet seen.
I didn't even finish it before
I called my agent and said,
I'm going to do this for sure.
It was really when
the CEO entered
the first time, and the
way the device-- the way
she chose to write
about that moment.
I knew that no matter
what came after,
that this play was
worth investing in.
And so we've worked
with different actresses
along the way.
And what I learned
then and what I--
I know from the beautiful,
beautiful ensemble work
that you will see on the stage
is, for this play to work,
there has to be a completely
democratic environment
in the rehearsal room.
And, fortunately, I have
true theater animals
in the ensemble who left all
ego at the door the minute
they walked into the room.
Made it about the
women's stories,
made it about the work.
And I-- you can say a
lot of things about me
as a director but,
probably easy probably
isn't one of the
things you could say.
DANAI GURIRA: I love it.
I'm like, Yeah!
LIESL TOMMY: It's a very
rigorous rehearsal room.
There is a great deal
of research that we did.
A very intense approach.
And, you know, the
devotion to the ensemble.
The devotion to putting
the women's stories
first is something
that we crafted
and it's what you see on stage.
What they do on stage
together is seamless.
Their kinesthetic
awareness of each other.
The way that they're
breathing, you
know-- my intention is always
for audiences to forget
that they're watching a play.
For them to lean forward so
they don't miss a single breath.
And I really believe
that with the work
that the ladies are doing
we are achieving that.
BONITA STEWART: Yes.
I would say so.
I mean I certainly think that
you captured that feeling.
If you have questions
why don't you
start lining up at the mics.
And this is really for everyone.
Anyone can jump in here.
But we started t o see
in my Netflix binging.
Sometimes it's occurring.
There's a number of,
now movies, whether it's
Beast of No Nation,
there was War Witch.
And to see the
struggles of what's
happening, whether it's child
soldiers as well as sex slaves,
you know, that are happening.
And here we are in the US.
Tell us how you were
able, as an actress,
to get into this character.
So if anyone-- because you
have different characters
that you play, but if anyone
wants to, maybe share with us,
how do you go about
making that transformation
into something that is pretty
horrific from our side.
SAYCON SENGBLOH: I
would say, personally,
I carry Liberia
with me every day.
Every day of my life
I carry the issues
that have come-- that
have happened as a result.
I carry the issues
that have come
as a result of the
civil wars in Liberia
with me so that pain is just
something that's very tangible.
My father was from Liberia.
He's now deceased.
My mother is American.
But my family was affected
by the war in separation.
And my sister's having to
leave Liberia and come here
to the United States,
on a personal note.
Then, as an actress I
did additional research
and studies.
We studied documentaries.
There are so many books and
journals and different things
that are available to us.
And I spoke with
people from Liberia
who had their own
varying experiences.
And, you know, it's a really
painful and serious thing
to perform this type of work.
Yes, there is so much levity.
There is laughter that you
would be surprised to see.
But people do-- people do often
laugh to keep from crying.
And so between the
reading and-- I'm
a very-- I personally
am a very visual person,
so I watch more videos.
I watch a lot of videos
and I listen a lot
to people talking-- talk radio,
talk-- people in little blogs.
You just go to YouTube
and-- go to YouTube
and put in Liberian tag and
you'll see all kinds of people
and their expressions
and their feelings.
And all of that sort
of, I use to motivate
what I bring to the stage.
But the script that she
wrote is so precise.
The character is on the page.
There's not a lot that we
have to do to bring that.
She she's written
it so precisely.
Every character,
I say, is written
within an inch of her life.
And so, it's just there and it's
just a really beautiful piece
to be able to do in that way.
AKOSUA BUSIA: I would
like to address--
I don't play one of the wives.
But when you said,
how do we address it,
because from your
side-- you know,
you're in the United States.
That's happening here.
And I found that
interesting because one
of the things I love
about Danai's play
is that, and actually
plays, because she
has another play like this,
is that there's a commonality.
You see, as you say
that, I'm from Ghana.
I came from Ghana
here a long time ago.
I live in Ghana now but
then I was coming here
and I was coming to do a film.
My mother was
absolutely terrified.
Because at that
time I was flying
into Los Angeles, California
where there was a huge Essence
article about how now, the
new prostitution in America
is with teenage
girls-- they don't
look like they used to with
the uniform-- the prostitution
uniform.
They're picking up pony-tailed
little girls at school
at taco stands.
They're putting them
in vans, and they're
running the train on them, which
I didn't know what that meant.
Now people probably do.
That terrified me, and
terrified my mother.
This is not their side.
This is us as women.
This is what they do,
in one form or another,
all over the world.
BONITA STEWART: Yes.
AKOSUA BUSIA: I've
read stories here
where you got police chiefs
in towns where they've
had girls locked up
underneath and they
found that some of the
police were going in there,
and the girls were chained up.
And until one of them escaped
and had a baby nobody knew.
This is not our side.
This is not your side.
This is the female side.
We are fighting a female war.
And that's the [INAUDIBLE].
BONITA STEWART: Well said.
Thank you.
Thank you for-- thank
you for clarifying,
because I do think--
just in talking
about the sisterhood and the
fact that this is historic,
you are bringing a
voice to all women.
And, quite frankly, putting
it at the forefront.
Because it really
can happen anywhere.
So thank you so much.
And you play the
peacemaker so well.
So well.
So questions for our cast.
Come on.
I know the Googlers.
I know you have questions.
Come on.
Yes, here we go.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
everybody for coming.
I had a quick question
for Danai and Liesl.
I mean, everybody in the cast.
After writing the characters,
and I haven't seen it yet,
I have my tickets
for next month.
How much change, once you
got into the, kind of,
ensemble rehearsals
and you started
to recognize, maybe,
new interactions
or new depths of the character.
Or how much was it
that you, kind of,
adapted to the characters
as they were on the page?
DANAI GURIRA: Actually,
because our first run at this
was at the McCarter in 2009.
And there were
rewrites happening
throughout that process.
And there were
things that, largely
was more dramaturgical, rather
than swayed towards the actor.
LIESL TOMMY: Which
means structural, right?
Like, this scene maybe, should
belong in act two rather than
act one-- maybe that's-- that's
when you're first starting
the process.
There's a lot of structural,
dramaturgical questions
that have to be ironed out so
that the thing makes sense.
And then you start, kind of,
ironing out the relationships.
And you kind of have to start
with the big picture and then
you can--
DANAI GURIRA: And just
to say, in addition
to something that was asked
earlier, the idea of what
these actresses have to do.
It is really-- we are asking a
great deal of the actress who
walks-- I mean she's
very kind, Saycon, to say
that I wrote them that clearly.
But we are asking for a whole
other level of commitment--
LIESL TOMMY:
Emotional commitment.
DANAI GURIRA: When we take
on an actor for this job.
Because they have to
be able to drop into--
to be in a survivor mode.
An, I'm alive and
I'm here and I'm
trying-- I'm going to make
it through this world mode.
And then drop into a
place of very dark trauma
at the flip of a coin.
Like, It has to
happen very fast.
SAYCON SENGBLOH: Yeah.
Liesl demanded that of us.
BONITA STEWART: And,
of course, Liesl
will demand that of you, which
is what's amazing about Liesl
also.
Because, I've worked with
other, many directors and some
are a little tentative about
how they push an actor.
Liesl, not tentative.
Never use that word to
describe this woman.
But, like, the idea-- it's
great because she was an actor,
and I think there's
an understanding
she has about when an
actor is holding back.
Well, I know there's an
understanding she has.
She understands exactly when
they're holding back, when
they're holding back too much.
When they're scared.
She gets when they're
scared and she
knows how to sever through
their pain and get them to--
- When they're playing too safe.
DANAI GURIRA: Their
most courageous place.
When they're being too safe.
And so that allows
this production,
and every production she's
helmed, to be dangerous,
which is what I love.
Because I want-- I want the
audience to feel danger.
I want them to feel
they are not safe.
Like these girls are not safe.
And that we can
take this anywhere.
And that's the power that
she bring so astoundingly.
And that we ask of
these amazing actresses,
to-- she was talking about how
she has got to get into it.
Because we asked them to go
so deep into the research
and the trauma, and things
that are dark, places
you don't want to go.
But then also know how to bring
that laugh about through living
on the other side of it.
So, I mean, it's pretty
amazing what these ladies do.
LIESL TOMMY: It is amazing.
And I also want to-- want
to add that we are all,
either from various parts of
Africa, I'm from South Africa.
Zainab is from Sierra Leone.
Lupita is From Kenya,
or the Caribbean.
Pascale's From Haiti.
And I felt that was
really important.
AKOSUA BUSIA: Ghana.
DANAI GURIRA: Zimbabwe.
LIESL TOMMY: You already said.
OK.
Akosua's from Ghana.
Zimbabwe.
And I thought that was really
important in the casting
process, because I-- I knew
how-- where we wanted it to go.
The depth that we wanted.
There's a lot of
things out there
in the world where violence
is a part of the storytelling.
But I always feel like sometimes
that violence is unearned.
It's cheap.
And for this play to do
what we wanted it to do
I felt that depth was the
most important thing for us
to achieve.
And the relationship that
every single one of these women
had to a country on the
continent of Africa,
their understanding of our
desire for specificity,
and they're also
understanding-- I
grew up during apartheid
in South Africa.
The concept of, cry
the beloved country.
You know, where you experience
deep, deep pain at what
your country has experienced.
You experience deep, deep pride.
But also the pain.
Which I don't know if every
American I've ever encountered
has that same sense
of personal anguish
about what you, your
people, and your country
have lived through.
And so that, that essence is
sort of the starting point
that every one of these
incredible women come with.
BONITA STEWART: Great.
Over here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
My name is Sophie.
Thank you so much for
coming today, and Bonita
for organizing.
It's so inspiring
to hear you speak.
And I can't wait to see the
play, which I haven't seen yet.
But I have a question
for Lupita, specifically.
Because I've been
amazed by what you've
been able to achieve
in such a short time.
And I was wondering,
because too--
I don't know your name but
the beautiful red skirt--
AKOSUA BUSIA: Akosua.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But I was--
I can relate to your speech
about, we're all
women, and we all
face, to some point-- to some
degree or another at limits.
And I think in the world
we all face limits,
whether we're women, whether
we're coming from minorities,
whether we are working
in tech and there
are more men than women.
There are always some barriers
that we can help break.
And I was wondering,
for you Lupita,
in a world, Hollywood,
that's so white,
and the latest controversy
about the Oscars,
demonstrate that again.
How have you been able to
make those barriers fall?
And so that they
don't limit you,
and not only do
they not limit you,
but you thrive in an environment
that's not very welcoming.
LUPITA NYONG'O: Well, Yeah, so.
I-- I always credit
my parents because-- I
was raised with a sense
of internal focus.
Like, there's the growing
up, and there's development
that you do.
And then there's the limitations
that the world puts--
imposes on you.
Those limitations really
don't have anything
to do with the person
you are or can be.
So, when it comes to Hollywood--
I mean, I grew up in Kenya.
I had this dream to be an actor.
I didn't have a plan for it.
I didn't know how
it could happen.
But what was instilled
in me was this idea
that you do your best
exactly where you are.
Like, you challenge yourself,
you compete with yourself,
first and foremost, before
you compete with anybody else.
And when that is the focus,
then you become your own bar,
you know?
And that's what you're
chasing, your own bar.
Not someone else's.
And I think that's just
the philosophy with which I
go about living my life.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Very inspiring.
Thank you.
BONITA STEWART: Right over here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
Hi ladies.
So nice to meet you all
and listen to your stories.
I'm from Uganda and I
am an African woman.
And I just wanted to ask
you, Danai, I think--
or-- the question is similar
to what, you know, she asked.
I think as African
women and girls, and men
we're raised to, sort
of, like Lupita said,
work hard, and stand
out, and do your best.
Like this is what
parents expect.
They don't expect any less.
But I think, when you
come here, there's
always-- there's not
enough space for everybody.
If there is one
African story running,
then they're kind of not
interested in hearing
another African
story at that time.
You know, if there's
Lion King on Broadway,
then there's no space for
another African story.
Or, you know, if there's a movie
you know, about-- there's not--
you have to wait.
Like maybe a few
years and then maybe
you can-- so I know that the
play started out off-Broadway,
and it did really well.
I came to see that.
And now it's on Broadway.
So I wanted to hear about
how you guys were actually
able to break those barriers
and tell this story, regardless
of what other African
stories are going on,
and how you've then able
to bring it to Broadway.
I know it's a long
story but, you know,
that sort of question.
DANAI GURIRA: I mean, in
terms of the barriers,
I mean it's really
beautifully said by Lupita.
It is that idea that--
the thing that you
said that was key to me was you
said, and then they tell you.
And the key thing, which
is what Lupita said,
is you don't listen
to what they tell you.
Those are imposed barriers
which have nothing
to do with who you are
or what your destiny is.
And I think-- I come across
a lot of young writers
who come up to me, young African
women, African-American women.
And that question comes up
about-- but they-- and I just
read this about this
theater not doing that.
And I'm like, what does
that have to do with you?
And it is a counter
way of thinking.
But it is actually
the way of thinking.
It is the only way of
thinking because we are,
and this is what we
have to bear in mind,
especially when you are,
for instance like you
and I, African women.
We are creating brand new paths.
There is no precedent,
largely and often.
So if you're looking for people
to tell you whether or not,
or what, or when, you
can't because they
don't know, because
there's nothing before you.
So you actually have
to lead the way.
And there are going
to be setbacks.
We had a setback with
this play six years ago
when it did not
come to New York.
And I remember lamenting to God.
And you know what I felt
spiritually, was, just
write the next one.
Just write the next one.
And so I had another
story to tell.
And I was going to make
sure I got that one told.
And that's what I did.
And then this one I
took care of itself.
Little did we know a
wonderful understudy at Yale
was going to turn
into an amazing star.
Thankfully we were
very sweet to her.
But that's the beauty.
I mean, that's a beautiful--
that is that astounding story.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Life
works out that way.
DANAI GURIRA: We
had done our best
we had competed with ourselves
we've pursued excellence
and we put it all out there
myself and Liesl and we knew
and some of the ladies on this
I must mention Pascal Armand
and John who were with
us back at Yale also,
who have held these
characters stunningly together
for a long-- and kept evolving
them into amazing realms
right now on the stage
where you see them.
And so, we did our all.
And then we-- you trust that
those seeds have been planted.
And sometimes they're not
going to sprout tomorrow.
And sometimes they're not going
to sprout for a few years.
But you keep going on with
your mission, and your destiny,
and your calling.
Because you're needed.
Your voice is needed.
It doesn't matter if
they don't see it yet.
The voice is needed and you
cannot listen to the they.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That is the truth.
PASCALE ARMOND: And not
only that but it's doubled.
It has doubled.
Because not only is Eclipsed
going on, on Broadway,
but Danai also has another
play off-Broadway, Familiar.
Another African story.
So if comes back.
It comes back and it multiplies.
LIESL TOMMY: I want to also add,
because I feel like both of you
asked versions of
the same question,
and it's a question that comes
up again and again and again.
Which is, how do we make
space for ourselves?
And, you know, I had a similar
parent situation as Lupita.
Which is that my
father was a Marxist,
so it was very hard core.
But what he always
said is, you do not
let the dominant culture
tell you who you are
or what your culture is.
They've got nothing
to do with you.
You ultimately will
be teaching them.
And here's an example, cause
I feel like we've sort of been
saying, just do it.
But there are
practical questions
around how do you just do it?
So for example, I'm working on
a project at Disney right now.
And it's a big project.
It's got about a
$28 million budget.
They've probably never
hired a woman of color
to helm a project like that.
The first thing I did
was hire an entire design
and creative team who are
basically people of color.
They've never seen that before.
Choreographer, set
designer, costume designer,
music director,
all people of color
because this is what I do.
I think it's my job to advocate
for women and people of color,
because I don't know
who else will, right?
So that's the first thing.
I don't ask for
permission, you just do it.
And then the next thing
was, I started advocating
for diversity in casting.
And I didn't ask permission.
The first presentation in front
of Bob Iger and Tom Staggs,
you know, there were just
people of color there.
And I could see that
people were startled,
because with Disney it's really
about the precise re-creation
of a film.
And there was a
lot of discussion.
I never got permission
because people were too
nervous to actually say yes.
And then as we moved
through the gates
I just kept pushing
it to the point
where now I have princesses
playing leads who
are white people on camera
but, in our production,
they're all people of color.
So you can't-- you just
have to forge ahead.
Trust your instincts
and, as Danai said,
you have to enact your mission.
Because if the
work is undeniable,
it doesn't matter
what people look like,
or what their sex is.
They're going to respond
to the work, right?
But if you ask
permission, or if you
think their rules
are your rules,
you're going to be screwed.
AKOSUA BUSIA: I'm so
glad Liesl said that.
Because I grabbed the mic from
Danai, because I don't want
it to be left out, which
you just addressed.
There is a financial
reality to all of this,
and unless you have
people like this--
because this play is
put on by the only two
black producers on Broadway.
And that is Alia Jones
and Stephen Byrd.
And there's a reality that,
who is going to take the risk,
as they call it,
and back something?
And it's generally
people of color
that will back people of
color, or they'll forget.
You know I had said this
before that, Lupita,
she was asked to do
something at the public.
And she chose this from
having done it at Yale.
And her star power
made them go, OK.
And then you get
producers who say,
I'll take the risk on that,
because other people won't.
Most of the Trip to
Bountifuls, and all
that, you've seen
on Broadway have
been by a production
team who are black.
I did a film years ago
called The Color Purple.
And Alice Walker and Quincy
Jones said a certain amount,
I think it was 50% or 60%
of the crew had to be black.
Now a lot of that crew
were not unionized,
had to get unionized, and have
been working on top, top films
ever since.
With the big name directors
because they named--
they worked with Spielberg.
Now they didn't get their
talent from working,
they got their
chance from someone
who wrote a book, and someone
who has the power to say,
this is what I need when
you're doing this project.
So there's also that reality.
And I'm an artist, and
an artist at heart.
So we love to just be
artists and, you know,
and you feel that--
finally my art.
But there's a financial reality.
And you have to
have that backing.
DANAI GURIRA: And yeah.
Just to throw in there also.
I've heard this sometimes.
Go where you're loved.
Sometimes people are-- they want
to go where-- what about them?
What about that theater?
What about those folk?
Go where your loved.
It might not be
where you expected,
but they're-- the people who
appreciate your voice are going
to stand underneath it and help.
The theaters that helped us
create and develop this play
will always be a part
of what it's become.
Because they loved
us, we went there,
and we were able to nurture it.
And so it might not always be
where you expect, but don't
always look at that, I want
that, it might be that,
and that it's great because
they believe in your voice.
BONITA STEWART: Great.
Over here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
First of all I saw the play
last night and you guys
were so amazing.
I can't-- I kind of can't
believe that you're at Google
right now, like, all of you.
But I was just
wondering-- so the play
deals with some really, really
heavy, traumatic, dark material
and-- I mean, in particular
I'm kind of always,
physically pained hearing
about rape in any context.
So I was wondering
how you, basically
keep from succumbing to, sort
of, hopelessness or depression
after living this material?
LUPITA NYONG'O: Well
I will say, may I?
The circle of trust that we
have built with each other
is something that, physically
and emotionally keeps me
together.
We have-- we've developed just
some organic rituals together
and we've played so
hard, and so open
heartedly together,
that it just feels,
like, it feels very safe because
we have each other's back.
And it's, in this play,
it's like a tightrope
between the five of
us on stage, that we
have to keep taught
the whole time,
and we trust each
other's weight.
We know each other's weight now.
And so we lean on that rope
and just hold it tight.
And I think-- had there been--
I mean, this ensemble, I
feel so blessed to be
with a group of women who
have similar work ethic
and just a [GRUNT] kind of,
commitment to the story.
I mean it's just, [GRUNT].
That's the only way to put it.
And so it's just
it actually is fun
because you know that you're
being held up by each other.
BONITA STEWART: Let's get
these last two questions in.
Maybe we can do it
a speed round so
that you do have an
opportunity-- the cast has
agreed to-- if you'd like
to take a picture you'll
be able to do so with them.
But let's try to get these last
two questions because there's
questions have been very nice.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Alright, thank you.
Hi I'm my name's Jan.
I saw the play last week and
I'm happy to use the discount
to take more women in my life to
see the play, thank you Bonita.
So, last week I
also re-read a book
that's very important
to me for colored girls,
that I read many times
at different stages
in my life to figure out my
identity in these spaces.
And so, I want to ask a
question about the decision
to keep this ensemble all women
and keep the crew all women,
similarly with for colored
girls it's all-female ensemble.
But, you know, when it was
adapted to a screenplay,
for instance, male
characters were
added and a lot of male decision
makers in reproducing it.
So how important is that?
Have you all faced
adversity with keeping women
as, you know, the center--
the crew and everything.
And can you speak to that?
DANAI GURIRA: Well, initially
yeah, the goal-- the vision
was to make it an all
woman-- to take out-- I
feel like there's this
thing that happens.
If you put a white
person on stage sometimes
in a black story, or you put
a man in a woman's story.
Suddenly that's where
all the focus goes.
And that's all
people talk about.
And I'm like, well how about
we just take that person out?
So now we only have
women to look at.
And you just remove
that problem.
So that was definitely
the goal with creating it.
You know, when you bring on
the collaborator in a director,
though I have seen-- it has
been directed once by a man,
I do feel absolutely
and completely, this
is a woman directed play.
And that's my thing now.
Just like it was
done in London and I
had to go choose a
director, and I was like,
just bring me
women, just chicks.
You know, of course Liesl is the
ultimate director of this play.
And so it is, very much so, I
think the places as was asked,
these ladies have to go to.
And the way that they have
to be driven to a very,
to the very edge, but
with vulnerability.
I just believe it requires a
very powerful woman to helm.
And yeah, the more we
can-- I mean the idea
of how it can
evolve beyond that,
I think retaining that as its
integrity, is crucial to me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Thank you for this
black girl magic.
DANAI GURIRA: Also, I have
to throw this in there,
we do have-- the producers have
created an amazing thing called
10,000 girls.
And that's also
about making sure
that more and more girls
get to see this, hopefully,
this example of an all
girl creative team,
an all woman creative team.
And so, girls and
women who would never
usually get to come to Broadway.
And they have raised
over $110,000.
They've brought in
3,000 girls so far.
That's only a third of the way
that we're trying to get to.
So 10000girls.org.
Check it out and help some
girls come see this play.
BONITA STEWART: And now
for our last question,
you're the sole male.
Lots of pressure here.
SAYCON SENGBLOH:
Proceed with caution.
We welcome you.
We love men, it's OK.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm like many
in the cast, I'm from abroad.
I'm from Uganda and Kenya.
I came here for college
I've been here since.
And I think that
maybe you guys were
agree that, one of the
things that helps you with
is just an adaptability.
The experience of living between
different kinds of cultures
and different kinds of worlds.
But sometimes it's funny for a
country like the United States
where there are so many
different mixtures.
Sometimes the pressure
would, sort of,
like to conform to the cultural
norms and that kind of stuff.
Either in the workplace,
whether it's on set or wherever
you work.
I think that for
you guys, I wanted
to ask how you sort
of manage making
sure you don't
compromise who you are
and where you,
sort of, come from?
Specifically in the
stories you write?
And whether there
is ever any pressure
to make sure there's a certain
kind of comprehensibility
for, let's say,
a local audience?
Even as you think about the
story you're trying to tell,
and even though it's very
specifically grounded
in a foreign culture?
AKOSUA BUSIA: I heard--
I heard you go, oh.
Like you had
something to say so.
I want you to talk.
You look so pretty,
you better talk.
PASCALE ARMOND: Well.
Well.
And I understand what you're
talking about, compromising.
And we sort of had to
do that with this play,
because when we went full
out on the Liberian accent,
people could not understand.
They were leaning
forward in their seats,
but for the wrong reason.
SAYCON SENGBLOH: And I get all
the Facebook messages about it.
LIESL TOMMY: We should have
Saycon do the pure Liberian
accent so that people
can understand the un--
understandability of it.
LUPITA NYONG'O: [INAUDIBLE].
LIESL TOMMY: Go ahead Pascale.
PASCALE ARMOND:
With doing that, we
had to have a
dialect coach come in
and tell us to put back our
consonants and everything.
And to make sure
that, now that we're
reaching a broader audience
who is more eclectic,
as far as where they come from.
They're tourists.
There are people from
different countries
that are coming to
see the show and they
may be used to
hearing one thing,
but we're doing
something different.
We're just like, OK so we need
to cultivate this in such a way
that everybody
would understand it.
However, people from
Uganda, Kenya, Liberia,
who have come to see the
show, they're just like,
you are great.
That was wonderful.
So we are, we're
riding that fine line,
but we're still
being understood.
And for the intents of being
understood so that people take
more away from it,
and not in our not
leaning in for
the wrong reasons,
we had to finesse
it in such a way.
Yes, massage it in such a way.
But compromising other aspects
of that, in who we are in order
to conform-- I don't do that.
DANAI GURIRA: And
honestly I think
that would defeat the purpose.
And I've come across
this question.
That's why I'm sorry
I'm jumping in.
I've come across this
question from Africans,
and I always say, if
we dilute ourselves,
then we're not
telling a true story.
And it's not compelling.
That's the irony, right?
The more we make it like
not truthful to who we are,
and what we do, and the
specifics of our culture, then
the less we actually create
something that's compelling.
And so, it's really
like, we have to-- I
do always pursue authenticity
and accessibility.
But that does not have
to involve compromise.
Because the thing
is, they, the they,
will dilute it for us
if we are not vigilant.
And part of, I think,
what we are after is,
once and for all,
for God's sake,
is seeing something
specific when
it comes to African
storytelling on stage, right?
The accent is actually
from the region, the music,
the clothes-- you know that
it's not-- so many times
I've seen something
that's about East Africa
and there's ladies with
black mambazo playing, which
is Southern African music.
And I just, and then
I have to turn it off
because I can't get involved.
It's just, if they didn't
make the effort, you know.
If you're making a French
film and suddenly you
hear Russian music playing,
it doesn't make any sense.
And we need the same level
of specificity and respect.
So, for me, why this is
successful is because we--
we're uncompromising in
the search for specificity.
Because other people can do
the other thing, and have.
DANAI GURIRA: It is a
daring thing sometimes.
My play the convert, the
first scene is all in Shona.
And I wrote it.
And I remember
writing it saying,
I don't think anyone is going to
produce this, but I don't care.
Because I is having such
a good time writing it.
And it did get produced a lot.
But the interesting thing was,
we created it in such a way
that I got-- the right
people came to it, in terms
of loving it in the
sense of saying,
let's bring out that Shona.
But let's just make sure
the action of the stage
makes it clear what's going on.
Pascale starred in that
as the convert herself,
and she had to do some
really risky stuff.
We had to keep it authentic.
It was in 1896.
So she wasn't wearing a shirt.
And that's how the
play started off.
She's topless.
LIESL TOMMY: Because Shona.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And ended.
DANAI GURIRA: Yeah,
and ended that way too.
And so the audience really
got to know Pascale.
But that was the
authenticity thing.
We had to do it.
BONITA STEWART: Well
thank you so much,
to the entire cast of Eclipsed.
I don't know-- I am leaving.
I'm going back to my office.
I am personally, just lifted.
And so I think it's
going to lift us
all going into the
weekend, hearing
the inspiration from these
phenomenal women and sisters,
I will say.
So thank you so much, everyone.
34% discount
go/eclipsed-discount
for your tickets.
And if you'd like to join
us on stage for pictures,
we welcome that as well.
So thank you for joining us.